one of the things that I noticed in
Bosnia that I was really struck by is
people didn't stop caring about the
things that people care about everyday
so I made friends with this one young
woman she was a Bosnian and she worked
on our staff as a translator or
something and she was a soulful person
and we became friends and she had great
great sadness in her but it really
wasn't anything to do with the political
or military situation that was raging on
around us all the time it was about her
profound sense of loneliness that she
had never really felt deeply mirrored in
a relationship and she longed for that
and that's that's where her energies
were that's where her heart was and I I
remember being struck by that it's like
we don't stop being human in the midst
of these calamities of course as one
might expect I'm spending a lot of time
in my practice speaking with people
about the disruption in their lives
currently but after a few minutes of
talking about how they're managing with
this or that people are still worried
about their families they're worried
about their relationships they want to
find love they want to be understood
they they want to find joy that is all
happening just in this different context
but the context doesn't erase those kind
of basic human things I mean of course
it impacts them I am finding that people
are facing unique challenges for example
in their relationships because of the
disruption or they're facing unique
challenges in terms of how they relate
to their career plans because of the
disruption but those basic things that
we all need haven't changed
I would say that I have a similar
experience Lisa that maybe in the first
five or ten minutes people are doing an
update about what they're circling
around on the news or some adjustments
they had to make but when we go right to
the dreamwork I have yet to have a
single dream about the coronavirus show
up in the practice people are dreaming
about family relationships they're
dreaming about their complexes or
they're dreaming about this tension of
values between two different parts of
their psyches or they're dreaming about
love and longing and that's the full
spectrum of the concerns of the soul
seem to continue to circle forward
despite the outer seeming of things so
the image that comes up for me as I hear
you to talk and I could say my my
experience in my practice is the same is
of the ocean and that even when the
surface is storm ridden choppy and
churning if you go down a hundred feet
or 200 feet or however far there is a
deeper layer that remains steady on oh
that the deeper layers of the psyche are
still there and that we access them in
our work with individuals and there's
something very deeply reassuring about
about that and about how the two of you
are expressing it is our depths are
still there
they are still speaking to us and they
are still concerned with the things that
are very deeply human and deeply
individual I absolutely love that image
but I think that's perfect
that the surface of the ocean can be
churning and even turning dangerously no
ships can get capsized and people can
get hurt but if we go deep enough down
in the ocean
there's little perhaps changing or even
going on in life moves forward as usual
in these mysterious places you'll need
rest this tension between what's
happening on the surface and what's
happening on the deep in the red book
and he introduces the idea of this voice
of the spirit of the times versus the
voice of the deep were the depths and as
he is negotiating these two values
inside of himself he feels this enormous
tension about what is he going to align
with and I think what he comes to is
that he needs to be able to hold both
that there is a voice that comes from
the top of the ocean and the sailors
that are crying out in the tumult of the
storm and at the same time there's a
spirit that comes from the bottom of the
ocean that says all as well and all is
held and all is sustained and part of
the human experience is to be able to
hold both as a way of being fully human
I'm just thinking of this quote from
young that I think kind of backs up what
we're all saying where he talks about
working with people who are dying and
watching their dreams and he concludes
that the self the deep part of the
psyche is profoundly uninterested in
death that it's sort of is a little bit
of a non-event and and again and there's
the sense that what's going on in a
surface may seem quite tumultuous but at
a deeper level things are just unfolding
as they need to well I think coming back
to the idea of the lightning struck
tower in Turkey 16 there are many ways
of interpreting that I mean in this
image if some are familiar there's a
tower on top of a mountain and perhaps
it has one or two windows and there's a
golden crown at the top often there's a
lightning bolt that's
you'll see a male and female figure that
are falling through the air or
ostensibly down into a fertile field one
of the ideas about the top of the tower
being exploded off of the structure is
the idea that certain events both
internal and external Depot's the power
of the ego and its ability to isolate
itself from life through constructs of
thought and perception and fantasies of
limitless power that events such as
we're experiencing right now close the
ego to have to feel small and vulnerable
and cast out of its certainties and
that's an opportunity for transformation
for many of us and a transformation that
we might not choose and given the
opportunity in an easy way but it's a
transformation that we can find
ourselves thrust into perhaps with a
willingness to embrace it